I went on Facebook the other night and I
was laughing I got to admit but I'm like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with Benji I I
read Benji's Facebook post to my wife
and she goes is he for real or is he
doing it to be funny I go I swear to you
I work with the guy over 20 years and I
don't know it's crazy this is what he
wrote I mean it's sort of weird if
you're having a dinner party tonight in
the New York City area
I'd appreciate if you'd invite me
especially interested in one that is
likely to have group slash around the
table intellectual funny rollicking
conversations
interspersed with and even about serious
topics
I would prefer this over a small talk
party where there are too many
one-on-one conversations going on and
it's too loud of a cacophony and it
hurts your throat to talk loud enough so
a cool dinner party old-fashioned kind
like in the movies with cool interesting
people and a room with good Acoustics
also please let me know if it's okay if
chick and my dog comes too but cool if
it's a human's only party and I would
love a vegan but okay if not and 100
don't expect this but if you have
calories for different dishes you're
serving that would be amazing
thank you Benji that is so ridiculous
Benji you don't want to be invited but
you want to know something like he put
it out there and then he did get invited
to a party and then I saw a ton of
pictures from the party uh-huh and but
would you answer me seriously just for
once or do you want to be Andy Kaufman
and like kind of keep up your persona
just let me know sure I'll answer you
seriously okay
what's going on with that
I I knew I think and honestly I think
I'm gonna unfollow you because if I'm
getting sucked into something
yeah it does it disturbs me if he's
doing it as a bid he can be doing bits
for my radio show and get paid
so I and I don't understand
I really don't get you I was feeling
lonely
and I so it was sincere like I do want
to be invited to dinner parties well
yeah go ahead JD maybe he does seem very
lonely because there are Twitter there's
a thing on Twitter where you can like
pop up and start having conversations
with other Twitter people so all of a
sudden I'll see a tweet come up and it
said it's a Benji starting this it's
called Twitter spaces and he'll start a
space and he'll say help me stop eating
for night and going into eating frenzy
binge
and then there's another one where it's
like uh please help me figure out
something with my headphones
and then another one talk to me while
you will do some things around the
apartment and I like I was the one and
some guy was like talking to Benji about
like going to a some concert a billy
eilish concert it's like random I don't
know I see either Benji's what are you
going for what is he going for JD
because I can't ask him what do you you
know I I don't know I think Benji he's
had said before he likes talking to
people and he likes you know so I think
but why not get a group of friends that
you really that yeah real friends
friends yeah
like when I feel like talking to someone
I call like my buddy Dr Lou like I know
him since fourth grade like like why why
does he have not have a real
relationship JD I I you know I don't
know Benji excuse me I'm sorry
I get better answers for a minute I will
say this I've known Benji for 20 years
and I don't know if I've ever met the
real Benji I think I've seen glimpses of
him I don't know there's always seems to
be something behind I love Benji I love
you but do it just always seems to be
something going on like he's working
something in his head or something you
know I don't know but uh
yeah he should be more like me and have
nothing in his head then he'd be safe
he's always working at something imagine
first of all going to a dinner party at
total stranger's houses you know that's
what I mean popping in yeah and you have
no idea where you're going who you're
going to be with
I don't understand that at all that's
dangerous
all right Benji thank you I see I've run
out of time moves fascinating
conversation I wish we could keep going
and going and going and it's nice to
check in with
big glad we're
[Music]
here